I wish to extend my sincere thanks for
the invitation to participate in today's
important international conference which
significant subject touches on the
willful destruction in some areas of the
world of the humanities cultural
heritage the horrible Dario franceschi
knee Italy Minister of Culture sends his
greetings and is extremely sorry that
owing to prior institutional commitments
he is unable to be present on his behalf
is therefore falls to me to present
before today's distinguish audience the
resolution of the Italian government
which will be submitted to that 196
session of the UNESCO Executive Board a
proposal already approved by the Italian
parliament during last week general
session that has already been welcomed
by director-general Irina Bokova
supported by many countries among which
Spain co-presenter with us France Russia
Morocco Algeria and China for the
creation of a kind of blue helmet
peacekeeping force to defend those
cultural heritage sites that are at risk
in the world Italy also proposes to be
the main point of reference for this
enterprise making available its
internationally recognized expertise in
the rescue and restoration of works of
art I would also like to remind you the
recent proposal that honourable see me
across the chair of the culture and
education committee the european
parliament has put forward regarding
attacks against the cultural heritage
describing them as war crimes against
humanity as well as unesco campaign to
prevent any dealings in antiquities from
iraq and syria and let me underline that
italy strongly supports this proposal
it is only too clear how determined
attraction of the some fanatical groups
capable of controlling vast geographical
areas are and how these actions want to
cancel the cultural identity of the
territory that they occupy at least 28
now I'm afraid there are 29 sides in
Syria Libya and Iraq are already lost
forever and again I underline this world
forever an activity that is blind and
barbaric which causes thousand hundreds
of thousands of victims and has in its
aim also to destroy the cultural
heritage of an occupied population
against this barbarity we have to react
we must define the cultural values
beyond our own borders for if these
torture countries are to have a better
future which we wish for them with all
our being this can only be obtained by
helping them recover their cultural
identity to finish I would like to
extend to everyone present my wish for a
positive and fruitful collaboration
thank you